what up space fam goes on here from
anime opera and i'm back at it again
with a new demonstrator video i said i'd
cover upper moon 6 if we got 7 000 likes
and as i'm writing this that video has
over 8 100 likes in like two days so
here we are thank you everyone who
showed that one so much love i think
it's fitting to do the other upper moon
6 next so if we get 7 000 likes on this
one then i'll get started on that one
asap if you haven't yet make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates a
quick thank you to bespoke post for
sponsoring this video bespoke post is a
monthly membership club delivering
awesome boxes of top shelf goods from
under the radar brands it's free to join
up and 90 of the products they offer
come from small businesses many of which
are based in the us every month they
introduce epic new products from outdoor
gear to clothing and bar wear and much
more the subscription box changes every
single month and every box has around 70
dollars in value but costs only 45
dollars you just take a quiz based on
your individual preferences you'll get a
box assigned to you before it's shipped
you'll get a preview of what comes
inside you can decide if you want to one
keep it two swap it for another box or
three skip the month entirely for no
charge you only pay for what you want i
got a sweet tonto knife that is just the
most beautifully designed knife i've
ever seen and i use it to open all of my
amazon boxes i also got a portable
fireplace which is not only super cool
but it allows me to make s'mores
anywhere i want you can even get a
freaking slingshot if you want to
channel your inner bart simpson i love
my experience with bespoke post and i
recommend checking it out for yourself
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at bspk.me
animeopro20 or you can just click the
top link in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all so as i mentioned in
the title we are starting with upper
moon 6 daki a part of the upper moon 6
team but not the whole of upper moon 6
which includes her older brother guitaro
2. when tanjo first stumbles upon doki
in demon form with her eyes reflecting
her upper moon status it is quite the
sight a woman is being absorbed into her
moving sash which is clearly part of her
blood demon art powers i like to refer
to her as like a more attractive doc ock
because of her sash tentacle controlling
powers right away she talks big she says
i have no use for any demon slayer less
than a hashira implying that she's very
strong and actually hopes that ahashira
one of the best fighters that
demonstrate has to offer shows up
immediately when tundra makes his
presence known to her he gets thrown
back by her sash before he can respond a
demonstration of her power and speed
tendril thinks to himself that she's so
fast he didn't even see her move tundra
immediately realizes that her sash or
obi is her weapon and it can swallow
people whole tundra also thinks about
how she can probably get inside the
piece of cloth too and use it to travel
behind walls and through cracks quite a
useful power for someone trying to hide
their demon identity and escape notice
daki is immediately impressed that
tundra survives her attack and remarks
that he's tougher than she thought then
she promises to pluck his eyes out and
eat them tundra realizes he can't fight
while carrying nezuko's box since it
might break the next time he takes a hit
like that and he puts it down telling
nezuko to stay there while he fights
tundra isn't getting very far with water
breathing so he knows he needs to switch
to hinokami kagura aka sun breathing the
style that suits him better once he does
this it appears like it might change
things doki appears to fall for his
after image and it looks like he sees an
opportunity to connect but then she
suddenly says even your best move is too
slow you bore me an opening thread
tundra saw disappears just like that as
she hits him and sends him flying
despite feeling exhaustion stiffening
his muscles tundra manages to get up and
keep fighting he notices her ob is as
tough as a blade which is quite
impressive considering how fast it is
and how many ob tentacles she can create
at once tundra is having no luck landing
a hit so he tells himself to raise his
body temperature for him as he explains
to a butterfly estate girl on flashback
a fever isn't a bad thing for him it
means he's in good condition and it lets
him use hinokamikagura more than once
and it does help although he's sweating
a lot he thinks to himself that he's
holding his own against an upper moon
which is pretty impressive when you
think about it remember upper moons are
supposed to beat hashira in battles
that's why they haven't been replaced
for over a hundred years and tundra is
not even a hashida but right away tundra
catches himself and feels like he's
being too optimistic it's not enough to
draw he has to win to save everyone
while tendril confronts daki inosuke
finds her lair and confronts her living
obi inosuke comes across a tricky
problem with docking her abilities the
ob is too wrigly making it hard to cut
and even if hinosuke did cut the ob as
it explains it's not the main body so it
wouldn't really matter zainto joins the
fight against the ob to help inosuke
impressing the ob with his speed and
what else is notable is that the ob
sensed him before he showed up but also
sensed another sound like thunder which
is of course tengen's sound tengen makes
his appearance in a flashy way of course
and the obi immediately takes note of
his power and realizes he's a hashira
the obi immediately sneaks through the
holes and escapes the obi reaches doki
before tangent can reach the ob and
donkey now reunited with the missing
fragment of herself transforms into her
stronger white-haired form it's also
pretty crazy how quickly the ob got
there she also seems to gain the memory
of the ob and remarks ahasha has finally
come his lordship will be pleased end
quote again she's excited and glad about
ahashira showing up which suggests that
she can take on a hashida and that it's
nothing to worry about she unleashes a
huge fast attack that slices through
surrounding buildings easily and even
some people in them tanjiro steps in to
protect a person and takes a big hit
himself and that person still manages to
get their hand taken clean off tundra is
of course angry that daki hurt innocent
civilians and that he couldn't save them
all it's at this point tanjuro remembers
a letter from ngoku's dad where he not
only apologized for his previous
behavior
but also told tanjiro that he's destined
to have even greater power than kyojiro
rengoku he says those destined to wield
sun breathing are born with a red mark
on their foreheads and although tundra
remarks he wasn't born with the mark
from the beginning of the series he did
have a mark and it just evolved from
there so i don't really get the point of
tantra constantly emphasizing not being
born with the mark and saying he's not
the chosen one just accept the fact that
you're the chosen one avatar the last
sun breather here we go seriously though
tanjuro points out how the first scar he
starts with he got from protecting his
little brother but it's pretty clear the
mark is special and not just the scar
anymore especially as it continues to
evolve over the course of the series at
this point something awakens in tanjiro
as he decides there are times in life
when you can't back down because there
are monsters who take life without
hesitation remorse or regret he's able
to surprise daki with his speed sneak up
on her and grab her leg he tries to
slice off her head when she manages to
get away tundra's grip was so strong
though she had to rip off her leg like
akaza did his arms to get away she's
visibly affected now and it seems like
tundra is finally on the offensive
tundra starts asking her why she steals
people's lives why she ruins them and
daki recalls she's heard something like
it before we see yorichi the strongest
demonstrator and first sunbreather
overlapping with the image of tanjuro
clearly they got similar energies and
tundra is a kind of successor for him
daki realizes these aren't her memories
but memories from the blood from muzon
from when muzon got traumatized by this
og slayer tundra then charges as she
surrounds him with eight razor-sharp
sashes as if she's trapping him in a
deadly spider web she thinks it's over
and it seems like it should be since we
know these sashes are as strong as
blades but tundra uses hinokami kagura
burning bone summer sun and cuts through
them like their paper because it's next
level sun breathing the wounds actually
burn and don't regenerate as easily she
realizes her hands are shaking but she's
not sure if it's her or muzon and if i
had to guess i guess it's musan's blood
ptsd from yorichi daki notices that
tundra is faster than before and that
tundras act like he can't even feel pain
tundra gets an opportunity to cut the
neck but she makes her neck a sash so
that tundra has trouble cutting it just
like inosuke did the cloth stretches and
tundra has trouble cutting something
with so much give she sends 13 ob at
tangent of this time tendril thinks he
can't dodge them but notices they are
moving slowly really slowly clearly this
is tundra stronger than he's ever been
he's unlocked a new level where doki's
attacks look like they're moving in slow
motion and his attacks burn and make
regeneration difficult tundra pins all
the ob down and cuts through them making
his way to daki she thinks to herself
how he's so fast and it really looks
like he could have won here but the
price of this advanced level fighting
hits tundra like a brick wall his
sister's spirit screams for him to
breathe and he stops before finishing
his attack which is a good thing since
he presumably would have died if he
finished it it's revealed that human
beings have two limitations they're
racked with pain and cannot move but one
can ignore this pain and keep going
fueled by anger so strong their eyes
bleed this is clearly what tundra did as
he kept going after receiving injuries
that daki said would have taken down
others we are further told to fight on
burns a human's life force their second
limitation once that life force is gone
death is certain tundra was about to
pass that limit we're told that if you
cross that threshold for even one second
even while fighting a demon you will
vomit blood for years crazy stuff and
we're told if anger alone could carry
you through then demons would have been
wiped from the earth it's a good message
anger is not enough but now you have an
exhausted tangero at an angry donkey's
mercy he can't stop coughing he can't
breathe his vision is going dark so
tundra did briefly surpass doki's power
even if it was unsustainable at this
point in his journey as doc he's about
to kill him nezuko comes in with an epic
kick that takes off donkey's head
notably if nezuko didn't come to the
rescue upper moon doki would have been
enough to take tunjiro out and then it's
mentioned that nezuko's anger is
infinite unlike with humans a demon
doesn't have the same limitations and
her anger drives her on until she wipes
her enemy from the face of the earth so
now we can measure donkey against an
angry nezuko and keep in mind daki
really wants to beat nezuko because
muzon asked her personally to finish her
off the demon that escaped his grip at
first it doesn't look good for a
precious demonic nezuko she quickly
loses an arm and a leg and is sent
flying into a building doki thinks since
nezuko doesn't feed on people that she's
a half developed demon and will take
long to recover she'll trap her in her
ob and then release her into the sun in
the morning that ob really comes in
handy for beating demons however doki
could not be more wrong about nezuko
nezuko regrows her leg quickly then her
arm doc even remembered cutting her in
half but nezuko is standing like nothing
happened daki says the very hype
statement that nezuku is regenerating as
quickly as an upper moon how crazy is
that this early in the story relatively
speaking and nezuko's being compared to
an upper moon level demon nezuko
undergoes her own transformation hits
puberty hard and i gotta say it is a
much cooler transformation than daki's
white hair transformation which wasn't
all that different our girl nezuko even
has a horn now which is awesome this
form is next level and nezuko has this
epic moment where donkey cuts off her
leg during a kick and isoko regrows it
immediately and completes the kick like
nothing happened slamming doki into the
ground at this point daki realizes that
nezuko has surpassed her in the sense
that her regeneration powers are even
greater than daki's own like with tundra
though there's a cache with this insane
new power nezuku is losing herself she's
gone berserk daki tries to use her blood
demon art to beat nezuko and starts
absorbing her into her obi but nezuko's
blood demon art even beats doki's blood
demon art she sets her blood on fire and
burns daki and is released from the ob
as a result she continues to stomp on
daki mercilessly before kicking her into
a building with people now here's the
problem this new unleashed demon nezuko
is awesome but doesn't have the same
self-control she used to have and she
lunges at a human luckily tundra has
recovered enough by this time to save
her from killing a human he holds her
back with his sword and it's definitely
a struggle in the meantime donkey is
shocked by nezuko's blood demon arc and
says it'll even take her a while to heal
from the damage tundra is stuck between
a raging nezuko and approaching daki the
need to save everybody in the building
and it really looks impossible but then
tangent shows up doki is actually glad
he's here saying it saves her the effort
of having to find him but man she hasn't
even recovered from nezuko yet and she
thinks she can take on a hashira pretty
crazy and then before any of us know
what's going on tangent performs an
ultimate flex after all the fighting and
suffering tundra went through to survive
this long against her tengan says she's
too weak to be an upper moon and slices
off her head without her or even us
knowing that he was gonna do it until
it's already done now this hypes up
tengen big time but it's a bit puzzling
how can a hashira beat an upper moon so
easily when upper moons haven't been
replaced in over a hundred years and
whenever an upper moon goes up against a
hashira the upper moon is expected to
win and if we're thinking that it was
too easy we'd be right despite the
disconnected head her body is not
crumbling tengen knows she's not strong
enough to be an upper moon but he
doesn't know exactly what's going on
daki is crying and asks someone called
gyutaro to save her then giuta or her
demon brother and the other part of
upper moon 6 emerges from her body to
fight tangent despite being fast enough
to cut off doki's head like it was an
afterthought misses giutaro and thinks
to himself that this new demon's
reflexes are incredible which is saying
a lot since tangent speed has been built
up big time up to this point but this
video is not about you taro smash that
like button until it's at 7 000 to get
that one back to daki and clearly daki
isn't that strong by herself compared to
the stronger demon slayers tangent of
surpassed her temporarily nezuko
surpassed her with her new form and then
tang in the hashira and now one of the
strongest hashra mind you flexes on her
straight up calling her weak multiple
times it's pretty clear to me that daki
would not be able to be an upper moon by
herself still we shouldn't go overboard
and say she's straight up weak she would
have beaten tanjiro if nezuko didn't
save him nezuko needed a new op form to
overpower her and we're told daki killed
and ate seven past hashira the
implication is she did it alone which
would suggest that this generation of
hasha is stronger than past ones and she
also tells tengen she never lost in
battle not once which is really
impressive if she actually went up
against multiple hashira however we
don't know the context or how the
specific fights went down or how strong
past hashira were but it's still notable
and serves to hype up how well tanjiro
and nezuko did against her now a part of
her power because of how their demon duo
works is that daki will not die until
you cut off her head along with utaros
at the same time and since kyotaro is
stronger as we'll get to see in the next
video this makes her quite difficult to
kill if you think about it it's very
lucky tengen brought strong
reinforcements because as good as any
hashira is daki could just get away from
gootaro perhaps using her ob ability and
then they would be practically
impossible to kill i'll also mention
that zaintoni nosuke take on daki while
tundra and tangent take on gyutero daki
does say with utero awake she can use
her full power and with the third newly
opened eye on her forehead she says she
can see everything every move they make
with gootaro awake our guys gotta avoid
poisonous blood blades along with the
obi as inosuke and zenitsu mention they
can't defeat her unless they work
together andinosuke using his unique
dual chip blades manages to use them
from different sides to finally cut the
tricky ob neck he runs with her head
like it's a football it's actually
hilarious until big bro gutaro has to
come to the rescue he gets a significant
hit on inosuke and a poisonous one at
that it would have even killed him since
gyutaro ain't for the heart but luckily
inosuke is so flexible that he can even
shift around his internal organs and
avoid lethal injuries so daki gets back
to normal and it seems like xenitsu is
the only one left who hasn't gotten to
flexon donkey at least temporarily so he
uses godspeed it's another one of those
op techniques that comes with a cost
sainitsu's legs will be shot afterwards
as he says but it's worth the insane
speed that is even so fast to daki we
are told that gyotaro could control his
sister and could see what she saw giving
him two points of view on what was
happening and this made him seem all the
more powerful now since it's not super
clear when he's controlling his sister
and when he's not and to what extent we
won't get too much into that here for
example was he to blame when he nosca
cut her neck he also blames her later
when she manages to get her head sliced
off again either way he does give her a
power boost through this and we should
keep that in mind that this is not just
her own pure power throughout the battle
anyways even with the boost she wasn't
able to kill inosuke and zenitsu and
back to zenitsu's attack he's almost cut
through but not quite it looks like daki
will attack him but inosuke shows up to
help and brags about being able to shift
his organs and not being affected by
poison because he grew up on a really
dangerous mountain this is why inosuke
is the funniest together they slice off
daki's neck as tanjiro with an enhanced
demonstrator mark makes his way through
guterres and they win they beat both
parts of upper moon 6. as i previously
mentioned they start blaming each other
as they are dissolving guterres suggests
daki should have finished off the
hashira when he was injured but daki
says he should have controlled her so
she did it so clearly he wasn't
controlling her the whole time later
muzon will say that daki was a hindrance
to gyutaro and that had gyutaro fought
by himself from the beginning the upper
moon would have won he's probably
thinking about how daki almost beat
tanjiro and dagutaro could have finished
him off immediately and then tanjiro
couldn't have grown over the course of
the battle and eventually become the one
capable of cutting off yootaro's own
head he might have been able to pick
them off one by one before it turned
into a group battle whether you agree or
disagree with muzon daki is viewed as a
failure here not only is she viewed as
inferior to gyutara she was straight-up
viewed as a hindrance by muzon as a
force that made yutaro weaker and yes
tundra temporarily overpowered her
nezuko did with her new form inosuke
with help managed to take her head when
she was supposedly at full power and
finally zaritsoni nosuke managed to do
it again by working together the fact
that she ate seven hashira is pretty
crazy that must be said and her blood
demon art is pretty useful too in battle
and when needing to move in and out of
places quickly however after seeing how
almost everyone out did her in one way
or another you start to wonder if she
had help from gyutaro with those other
hashira or whether she got lucky or
whether those old hashira were just
significantly weaker than this
generation's hashira which is probably
my go-to interpretation and if we
believe the latter then rather than
making doki look weak it hypes up this
generation of hashira and also the level
of strength that our main cast has been
able to reach up to this point in the
story so yeah that is it for donkey the
weaker part of upper moon 6 and
potentially you can even call her the
fake upper moon that didn't fully earn
her spot in muzon's eyes if you do want
to see the gyutaro video smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is hashtag energy and
passing is fake upper moon energy so
choose wisely if we can get 7000 likes
on this one i repeat 7 000 then i'll get
started on the gyutaro video asap if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you